we covered the bulk of the policy fiascos
and the diplomatic errors of the [inaudible]
Trump administration at the g seven meeting
in France over the last couple of shows and
today I have sort of like a sideline story
from the g seven that's just genuinely bizarre.
Donald Trump said at the g seven earlier this
week that his wife, Melania Trump, has gotten
to know North Korean dictator, Kim Jong, Boone
and Melania having gotten to know Kim Jong
Moon, believes that Kim Jong Un really has
the potential, I guess to turn around North
Korea now, even if all of this were true.
I don't know why we would care about Melania
Trump's opinion about the DPRK.
I don't know the answer to that.
I don't think we would care.
But the more important thing is that Melania
has never met Kim Jong.
Go and take a look at this video of Donald
Trump.
Kim Jong On.
I've gotten to know extremely well.
First Lady has gotten to know Kim Jungen and
I think she would agree with me.
He is a, a man with a country that has tremendous
potential.
You're in between China, Russia, and South
Korea.
Now, the White House spokeswoman later said
Melania has actually never met Kim Jong Moon.
Uh, and, uh, the, the questions immediately
swirling question one, is it possible that
it's Ivanka Trump that meant Kim Un and Trump
is confused between Melania and Ivanka?
Uh, he's made similar comments about both
of their bodies over the last 10 or 15 years.
Maybe the confusion goes beyond just seeing
them as being similarly well endowed or something
like that.
What was the official explanation?
Because there is an obvious impossibility
here.
Trump says Melania has gotten to know Kim
Jong Moon.
The White House says Melania has never met
Kim Jong Un.
How could both be true?
You're going to like this.
Stephanie Grisham, the White House spokeswoman,
said President Trump confides in his wife
on many issues, including the deep tailed
elements of his strong relationship with the
Chairman Kim.
And while the first lady hasn't met him, the
president feels like she's gotten to know
too.
Why does he have to lie about the dumbest
things?
The answer is that it's simply comes naturally
to him.
It's reflexive, it's possibly even pathological
for him.
And of course, this raises the question of,
has Trump shared confidential, classified
or otherwise sensitive and secret information
with Melania Trump?
That would of course be a concern as well.
And to be perfectly frank, I'm more interested
in whether Melania Trump has gotten to know
Justin Trudeau, uh, looking at very, very
friendly greeting each other at the g seven
while Donald Trump stood aside.
Anyway.
Uh, there is one other possibility may be
Melania Trump and Kim Jong-un have met and
it's being covered up, although it doesn't
seem like the most likely thing.
I don't recall Melania Trump even, uh, attending
the trips during which Donald Trump met Kim
Jong and all very weird.
The most likely explanation is the simplest
one, the one that requires the fewest assumptions,
which is Donald Trump just made it up because
he makes things up on the spur of the moment
all the time.
And then later, somebody's got to clean it
up for him.
But in the words of the Trump is defenders,
he's a politician.
All politicians lie, but at least he's doing
the right thing.
Remember the takeaway which I mentioned earlier,
you can't believe anything Donald Trump or
his administration say without further researching.
At first, the most basic pedestrian assertions
by Donald Trump need to be interpreted as
potentially lies until you've actually gotten
independent confirmation.
That's the real takeaway from the [inaudible]
for me.